Oh
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Monday it is a semi beautiful day
here in New York but you know every day
is the same when you're staying inside
hijacks thanks for having me here today
on your web show I'm really excited to
be here it is Monday on what hopes to be
a very short nice and uneventful week
here in New York it is it is kind of an
important day because it's 4/20 which oh
my god yeah 4/20 light up for the Green
toasters is like a major holiday but for
the Austrian Emily and Troost teens it's
an even bigger holiday because it's
Theo's birthday yeah Wow and I brought I
brought him here for a world class
interview is that okay oh my god I would
love that how old is he in human years
I think he's turned 3 or 4 hi Theodora
how old are you
it is Theos 21st birthday therefore his
he third dog birthday 21st human so he
can officially drink at his next
birthday he'll be older than us oh my
god happy birthday Theo you don't look
older than 15 angel muffin boy I have a
very long instagram caption headed you
guys his way because there's just so
much love in my heart for Theo and I'm
just like excited to celebrate him even
though like every birthday is the most
depressing day of my life
oh of course because it's you know like
a morbid reminder of the sad reality
that is like oh god I don't know if
anyone just saw me accidentally drop
Theo but PETA is gonna be over here
inside [ __ ] minutes oh my god well
happy birthday Theo I wish we were all
celebrating together we'll do a zoom
happy hour for him to him every time
it's the o's birthday i just feel like
it marks like a big chapter like I
remember the first birthday that we
celebrated it celebrated at the new
studio with Theo it's just I couldn't
remember the hugging I show you a
picture you'll remember someone edited
him to have a little bogey oh yes
time is flying that's for sure I
remember that and then I think I
remember that was his second birthday I
think Jackie mmm yeah for sure yeah
second birthday
well happy birthday Diggs I wish I wish
we could be there that's all I could say
it's such a it's a sad enjoy a stay it's
what the folks call bittersweet totally
bittersweet I just I wonder if he knows
it's his birthday
no we like through him like a little
party last night like cheering and he
all he wanted to do was go to bed I
can't Wow okay well how was your weekend
not great I'm not gonna lie and I'm sure
a lot of people are tuning in like just
to hear me speak on this and I wanted to
get it out right in the beginning so no
one has to scroll through a podcast
looking for it I really had a bad
weekend I was like in such a lull
because I got myself into like a major
mess on Friday night and then I just
couldn't stop thinking about the mess
the whole weekend and like what a [ __ ]
I am and for those who don't know I
posted something on my Instagram story I
was recapping One Tree Hill and not that
it matters but context is relevant and I
was talking about season 4 when Payton
has that guy posing as her brother and
he ends up like being a stalker and
breaking into her house and I just I
posted something so dumb I was just
saying like what didn't think was gonna
happen she had like a 24-hour webcam in
her room like and then she got a stalker
like I obviously I was just recapping a
TV show like not realizing like real
life and so in my mind when I posted
that like it made sense but then I got
like a DMS immediately from people being
like what the [ __ ] did you just say and
once I started reading those DMS this
like light bulb went off in my head and
I was like [ __ ] and I immediately took
it down like I realized what that
interim story meant in real life like
outside of Tree Hill right do you know
and it is not good no it was not good it
was victim shaming for like a woman who
was a victim of violence like I don't
even know what I thought I was doing it
was so weird and like I feel so
disassociated from it now cuz like I
don't even believe that like why was i
posting that i was just like looking for
something funny to say on instagram and
like that's not even funny so I thought
about you DMS about it and then a bunch
of the toasters in the Facebook group
were expressing their disappointment and
I obviously immediately took it down
like the second I realized what it
actually meant and then I also
apologized in the Facebook group because
letting people down but I wanted to come
on here on the podcast and apologize one
more time because I feel like I owe that
to everyone like people saw and they
were really triggered by it like people
who are survivors or victims of abuse
and I just well I don't know why I
posted that and I wanted to come on the
podcast and let anyone know who saw it
and who was triggered by it or who was
upset by me like you totally aren't
entitled to do that and I'm totally
wrong and I'm owning it and I realize
how dumb it was to post and I really am
genuinely sorry like I'm not I'm not
apologizing because people are mad at me
or like there was backlash like I'm
apologizing because I genuinely like
realize the gravity of my words and I
know that I was wrong and I say this all
the time on the show like people are
human we talk about canceled culture a
lot and like as long as you're willing
to own your mistake like and understand
why it was problematic like we have no
choice but to understand that and I
always handle things like as a as a
influencer whatever I am and then also
as like a consumer like I love people in
pop culture and they [ __ ] up all the
time and I always handle things how I
think I would want my favorite podcaster
youtuber to handle it so I'm trying just
to to own it as best I can you know we
come on the show every day and like we
hold other people accountable for like
their messes and like things they say
and do and I'm no better I have to do
the same I probably have to do it even
more loudly because I call other people
out I have an obligation to do better
because of the platform that we have and
I really [ __ ] up this weekend and I'm
really sorry like I genuinely like in my
soul I'm sorry and I know that people
like it ruin their weekends too like
they saw it on Friday and they had app
it all Friday because of what they went
through
like I just why am i giving people pics
like so that's not my job it's opposite
like just shut the [ __ ] up Claudia yeah
well it's good of you to apologize and
you know that's all we can do is try and
be better moving forward yeah and I
understand that there are people who are
just upset with me and don't want to
hear what I have to say and I respect
that too but I feel like for my own soul
like I can sleep at night knowing that I
apologize like that's all I can do I
really I genuinely am really really
sorry like I [ __ ] up and I know why it
was wrong and I know that that's like a
really [ __ ] up way of thinking like I
don't even believe in victim shaming I
don't know why I said that it's like you
get so disassociated from yourself and
like from reality when you're recapping
a TV show and like you say things about
people in the TV show you would never
say about like your friends or people
you know ya know and we've gotten like
so caught up in talking about old shows
and you know just being super critical
of them um and so it happened
your apology is very heartfelt and I try
I try I know I let people down and some
people just shot when I hear from me but
I didn't want to come like we we have
found ourselves a few times before like
in situations like this and I genuinely
try and handle it like like I would want
someone I like to handle it and so I
just wanted to be open and honest it's
like when we talk about Real Housewives
like everyone's entitled to make a
mistakes but if you don't own it and
like what's the point yeah and I think
we are forgiving towards other people I
think most people are forgiving so
that's that's all you can do at this
point is just let everyone know how
sorry you are and you are very very
sorry I am a great but I don't want to
like tamper on see his birthday so I
just wanted to get out I hope everyone
can move past it in their own time with
me and dive into the past moment if it
takes people time then it takes people
time you know I'm very sympathetic
mm-hmm you know this weekend was just
her rough one I don't know if like it
was just for us or for everyone I just
felt like this was like a turning point
in the weekend where I'm just sort of
like giving up you know yeah like we
have a whole nother month I think this
morning it was the mayor of New York
just canceled events through June and I
don't know what that means for like
getting back to normal society but it
doesn't look good you know I think this
last week made it very clear especially
in New York that we are not going to be
returning to normalcy really anytime
soon or anytime that anybody thought I'm
still holding out hope for June 1st to
be like the start of something new
but that does seem to be getting like
further and further away yeah I I would
agree with that and I actually had hope
for June 1st also until today when it's
like Gay Pride has canceled concerts in
June are canceled so what are we gonna
be able to go to restaurants clubs I
mean that's
interesting I do feel like canceling
those events in June like might be the
right call because we might just be
returning to normalcy and to really
really flatten the curb like why should
you know 100,000 people get together for
pride like if it is a health hazard
so yeah I do see like we could go back
to normal life at a lesser level yeah
and also those events will require a lot
of planning so if there is you know the
possibility that it's not gonna happen I
feel like even the event organizers
would want to know like either to
postpone or like 2021 is gonna be the
biggest pride we've ever seen totally
sweet okay well we have the fast five
stories for you today
um we've got some good stuff I think it
rounded out pretty nicely you know so I
have a weekend so we had the the
fortunate break in three days where it's
like when you have to do a show day
after day and there's barely news on
Monday like what's to say there's gonna
be news on Tuesday but at least we
haven't reported the news since Friday
yeah um this weekend for me though like
was the first weekend where I'll it
spent the whole 48 hours in bed um like
I only watch TV I actually watched him
good stuff I'm excited to share with the
class at the end of this episode um so I
like was I was barely even on my phone
so looking at the news say I'm like oh
wow here's what's going on so are you
ready to get into the fast 5 stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast oh I am but I do have a question
for you before we get started
ooh and this is not a setup for an ad I
was just curious if you got hung over on
Sunday because I didn't speak to you oh
so okay I was hung over so we did it up
zooom happy hour except it's not happy
hour for us because we started at like
8:30 we did a zoom Oh Saturday night
zoom it's a party on Saturday night and
I drank pretty much like a whole bottle
of wine by myself and I was hungover as
I was sleeping like I woke up at 6:00
a.m. like hungover I woke up like every
hour hungover when I woke up one time in
the morning I took one of my migraine
pills cuz I had a headache and by the
time I woke up at like 12:00 physically
I felt okay mentally spiritually
emotionally I was not okay and it
reminded me why I
do not drink I that feeling is the worst
feeling in the entire world I will go
out of my way for the rest of my life to
avoid it so you will not see me drink
again for another six months oh my god
everyone was so excited on the zoom that
you were drinking and I had so much fun
but it just wasn't worth that feeling
yesterday of like wow I'm a worthless
piece of garbage I don't know why
alcohol just makes me feel that way
but can we work through that that
thought process because what would make
you be a piece of [ __ ] I don't know just
like everything it just like hangs over
me
and I and I don't and also like I wasn't
feeling great physically like I didn't
get had betted in peloton and then I'm
just like having a worthless day being a
worthless person but that's what
quarantine is worthless people doing
worthless things no this was like the
first weekend in quarantine where I was
truly worthless like I've been working
really hard to like stay above that line
I posted my patron day in the life video
and even though it's so boring and
depressing but you see a girl who's
trying to make the best out of her
situation totally like I watch that
video and I was like this [ __ ] does a
million things in a day like I don't do
anything and people were like Claudia
you do want and like I actually can't
like if I've recorded today like it
would be the toast and then bed so I'm
not I'll have to come up with another
funny video concept because I can't - of
a day in the life log no it was it was
really hard to do I hope people in
somehow enjoyed it I mean it's just real
like that's really what I'm doing but I
feel like for the last month I have made
a conscious effort every day to like
keep some semblance of normalcy
be a little productive feel okay about
myself do one thing every day that like
the I don't really want to be doing but
I'm gonna do it whether it's pellet
hunting or starting a new book whatever
um but this weekend was the first time
where I was like I'm giving up and I
don't know if it's the alcohol I don't
know if it was the extra months tacked
onto quarantine I don't know but like I
don't want to be that person so it's not
drinking means I won't be that girl and
I can keep with my with my what's it
called like arbitrary activities then
that's what I'm gonna choose to do okay
well I do have another question for you
totally unrelated I know you said that
you wanted to dive into the past five
and I totally respect your feelings like
you know you're my sister and I
absolutely love you but I wouldn't be
like my stomach
like I would get a little maybe a small
case of RDH no I fit in let you know
that today's episode is brought to you
by stamps calm
we need to avoid crowds any way we can
right now but what if you need to go to
the post office what if you need postage
to send out letters and packages
don't worry stamps comm is here to help
anything you could do at the post office
you could do at stamps calm print
postage on demand to skip those lines
and crowds at the post office plus you
can actually save money with discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office
now of course during quarantine we
should be avoiding the post office at
all times like also during regular life
the post office is not a place I ever
want to be so stamp stuck home is a
great thing for quarantine and then a
great thing for life after quarantine if
we ever get back to it they bring you
all the service of the US Postal Service
right now to the computer and the safety
and comfort of your own home office or
anywhere else you're hunkering down
right now whether you're a small
business sending invoices online sellers
shipping out products or you're just
working from home and need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle all of it with
ease use your computer to print any
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
package or any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
leave it at your mail carrier schedule a
free package pickup or drop it off in a
mailbox and no human contact is required
it's that simple and like we said this
stamps.com you can get get great
discounts - five cents of every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off usps
shipping rates and now in addition to
offering discounted USPS stamps the USPS
rates Samsung also offers UPS services
discounted rates up to 62% off plus with
stamps com you won't even have to pay
UPS residential scepter jizz right now
our listeners can get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
calm clink on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in toast
that's stamps calm click the microphone
at the top of the home page and enter
toast toas tea stay safe my friends love
it sign on get stamps okay the first
story is a little sad news it's mostly
for you it came out literally Friday
right after we finished doing the toast
but Taylor Swift has canceled her 20/20
tour dates due to the coronavirus crisis
Taylor Swift has canceled her 20/20 tour
dates including her lover fests due to
the corona virus pandemic her planned us
shows will instead take place in 2021
quote I'm so sad I won't be able to see
you guys and cons
this year but I know this is the right
decision she tweeted on Friday please
please stay healthy and safe I'll see
you on stage as soon as I can but right
now what's important is committing to
this quarantine for the sake of all of
us you know we love a role model setting
a good example to be honest I didn't
have lover fest tickets yet and it was
like such a [ __ ] to get them I
can't believe people are gonna have to
go through that whole Ticketmaster
process again like it was traumatic
enough the first time but like I always
think of things selfishly at first you
know like I didn't have tickets yet like
I was probably gonna go so now I'm just
going next year like I didn't really it
wasn't really real for me like it wasn't
tangible because I was like
hypothetically going you know yeah yeah
it wasn't like Kelly Clarkson intoning I
didn't Las Vegas like we had this
fabulous booths like with these seven
tickets that we paid a lot of money for
and we didn't even get a refund I know
and weirdin get to go like to have that
experience in those memories but it just
means that when we were able to go we're
gonna have an even better time imagine
how insane lover fest is gonna be or
anything that Coachella stagecoach now
that everyone who like is biding their
time six months all they're thinking
about is how excited they are and the
energy is just gonna be on another level
I'm really looking forward to the post
Corona energy that's true I think
everyone is gonna put forth the Seanie
vibes that like we've been talking about
for so long like licking the subway you
know hugging strangers like that's the
energy I'm really really looking for no
I think I think that after this like
people are actually gonna stop licking
the subway and stop hugging strangers
like I think that's gonna be a permanent
change you know that guy in Washington
Square Park who runs around like NYU
campus with a sign that says free hugs
maybe I don't know I didn't go there I
do believe he is officially out of
business yeah but maybe he could say
free peace signs yeah or free advice mmm
he looks like wise I'm sure I'll sign up
here he's seen a lot in that Park
Jackie also you should just literally
like sit your ass down in the park with
the chair and like a table and give free
advice cuz you give great advice you
should charge people thank you no I'll
give it for free but like I guess that's
like Deer toasters but then when we do
deer toasters I don't feel like I'm
giving great advice no we're really
harsh ha
oh yeah I once saw a comment that I
didn't disagree with we're the persons
like anytime anytime there's a dear
toasters you guys roast the person who's
writing in yeah because you and I both
really pride ourselves unlike being
devil's advocate but then I play devil's
advocate and I start to agree with the
devil no it's I really pride myself on
the fact that I think people are really
incapable of seeing any perspective but
the one that they're in and even if you
end up being right it's important to
just try and see it from someone else's
perspective because it might look so
different
I think perspective is everything we
always say that on the toast it is truly
everything and I just want to say we are
harsh but sometimes we're totally right
like last week someone posted in tipsy
toasters like hi my boyfriend of five
years literally just broke up with me
for no reason what are we drinking and
then in the comments section she was
like I should have listened to Jackie
and Claudia over a year ago in our pink
studio she had written in and she only
clipped like the last five minutes but
what we said was like this guy doesn't
sound like husband material like get rid
of him Wow well I love to see that well
I'm sorry about the breakup but no I
love to be right but I'm sorry that your
feelings are now like up her and your
boyfriend broke up with you but now you
feel like you'll trust us coming forward
maybe maybe sadly what we need is trial
and error
sadly okay next story the one world
global concert raised more than 127
million dollars for the who Emergency
Response Fund ok Saturday night the one
world global concert for who took place
on the television literally everywhere
every Network every streaming platform
like where ever you except for on our
zoom like I'm surprised there wasn't a
little they should have been allow you
to add the concert to your zoom and then
we could all watch together yeah well it
went down on Saturday night some of the
big I mean the biggest names in music
participated I want to get your thoughts
on some of the performances I caught a
few of them not all of them it was a
very long but for me the highlights
where Kacey Musgraves singing rainbow
like there's no more pertinent song Lady
Gaga singing smile there's no more
pertinent song
um and those weren't the two highlights
of things that I saw I thought that
every woman's song selections were
really really interesting like obviously
my favorite was Taylor Swift just
because I absolutely loved her but she
performed soon you'll get better which
is a song from her album that's about
her mom's journey with um cancer she's
been diagnosed with cancer I think twice
definitely more than once I'm not
entirely sure she's very private about
it um and she has said when she was
promoting her album and doing interviews
that like should probably never perform
that song it's just like deeply painful
and very very personal um and then she
just went on this telecast and performed
it because it's so pertinent like you
could listen to the lyrics and
canoodling it's so pertinent like it is
yes what is going on right now and you
listen to the lyrics and you're like is
this about current virus like it
actually feels like she wrote it about
so I'm glad that she performed it and
that like she didn't have to do it on
stage like she was able to do it in her
house she kept looking over her piano I
feel like her mom was standing there so
I just loved the bravery and I love her
and I love Lady Gaga like live-streaming
on Instagram herself watching the entire
broadcast like literally sobbing when
Taylor Swift was on like I just love
Queens respecting Queens yes Lady Gaga
is also crying when Billie Joe Armstrong
saying uh wake me up when September ends
did then catch our performance no
Bennett has his head like permanently up
like he doesn't even know what goes on
in the world like he's just literate in
two months I'll be like by the way did
you see this billy joel armstrong thing
oh my god that's so funny
is it Billie Joe or Billy Joel Armstrong
but in the silent L just in case I had
the same thought as I'm about to say it
and then I was like let me say it so
that it's in a way if you think it's Joe
it sounds like Joe and if you think it's
Joel you can make a Joel out of it
that's what I did it's definitely not
Joel because we're just saying Billy
Joel I told it like if we had to just
please do that I would have said Joel no
I would have said Joe for sure she's
always a funny it's not a bad name by
any means but there's something about
the way your mouth has to contort when
you say it Joel
there's you know it's still funny we
were having this conversation on our
zoom like about how names like it's hard
to think of a name arbitrarily without
thinking of the name of the person that
you know with that name so we were
talking all about like our future baby
names and we were just saying like how
one person can ruin a good name yeah and
that's just somebody but then it's like
one person can save any like stormy
Webster stormy danger what was her name
stormy Daniels Daniels Daniels yeah yeah
I agree with that one person can change
the world
just one thing I did want to say about
one go ahead Foreman is like zoom is
fundamentally so hard for us because
zoom will not allow you to talk over one
another so like honestly maybe this is
the exact exercise we needed in order to
perfect our show you know and have that
separation of Jackie and Claudia please
continue oh how about that's good like
when you're done talking say what do you
think Jackie or look what do you think
Claudia now I know why news anchors are
so wonky back to you Claudia in the
field thanks Jackie
what I was gonna say quickly before we
move on from this concert story is two
things I've been seeing like the number
of money reported everywhere 127 point
nine and I just don't know why they
don't say 128 million well that's kind
of like how in my um in my patreon day
in the life video I show my palette on a
lifetime like history of since I thought
in the peloton so I was like you guys
all know I got it during quarantine this
is how much I've done and I've had done
16 hours and 59 minutes and I said I did
16 hours and like it's bothers me like
why didn't I just take that minute why
didn't I take that win that's weird I
know but it's cuz I saw like the first
number first and I just went with it and
you would rather be someone who's like
oh we actually made a little bit more
than what I said then oh no you didn't
actually hit that number that's
definitely true you know the other thing
graphics you'd rather be modest than a
liar yeah of course and when you over
exaggerate like people stop believing it
like I'm going through that right now
where I think everyone like my close
personal friends like
know that I've started to exaggerate so
much that they just don't believe
anything I say is true yeah sometimes I
did I I find myself in that situation
with you ya know I know that you like
don't believe anything I say like if I
tell you something like a fact check it
yep well there's a few different things
one you're an exaggerator - like you're
a jokester
you might just like be pulling one on me
so any so if you're saying a truth I
have to I have to vet it first okay so
that's that on that the other note I had
was the Little Mix performance from this
concert did you see it no and you know
I'm their number one fan they were my
number one most listened to artist in
2010 decade so they were fabulous like
they sing all their four-part harmony is
totally separate I loved seeing little
like bits of their houses because
they're all just like such glamorous
girls but I did believe their song
selection was kind of strange because it
was touch which I first I understood
like we can't touch people but it's a
very sexual song yes with you a go into
the zone I remember all the places you
wanna go oh yeah it's like an organizing
take me all the way touch your love is
enough to knock me off my feet he did
maybe I was singing touched by ariana
grande then yeah I wasn't really
familiar with the song that you were
seeing but I thought maybe it was a part
of the song I didn't know it goes like
just to touch your love is enough to
knock me off my feet boom I was singing
touch it by om grande just a touch your
love just to touch your love is enough
to make me numb noni it's just like a
sexual song it's like you and I and
nobody regardless of that like we're not
supposed to touch right now they have so
many good empowering songs you know what
I'm just gonna make a little suggestion
just in case we're in quarantine for a
lot longer in the wings is inspiring
wings is so inspiring salute is
inspiring so yes we salute our health
care workers yes Oh power is inspiring
yeah maybe that was the easiest one for
them to perform separately like with
four different harmonies but I just
thought it was a
your song selection and I love them yeah
I would agree with that
okay well I'm still gonna check it out
cuz I love them so much like each one
individually more than the next I can't
even I don't know if you follow them
from the toast but I follow them on
Twitter um and it's just a great place
to like constantly and just know what
they're up to I follow them on my
personal Instagram they do and the group
Instagram the little mix Instagram does
a good job of like sharing the
highlights from their personals you know
so I feel like I only really need to
follow and they might follow Perry
because I turned her boyfriend are
everything have you seen their tic TOCs
yes I have the one with the stairs I can
swear yeah um it's so good and it's just
the craziest part is that she was
engaged to Zane oh I don't know if this
is a story
um but Liam Payne was on Instagram live
with Alessa was it a story it would it
got bumped at the last minute so let me
just make note of it for some members so
that's an ounce for the One Direction
stands who are looking for some sort of
update Liam Payne was on Instagram live
with elasto and they were just chatting
and it basically said like in a recent
interview he said way too much about the
One Direction reunion like Harry Styles
was yelling at him so he has to turn it
down but he was like Alesso you could
join us and fill in for Zayn so Zayn is
not coming Wow Wow
but they get a One Direction following
him a One Direction X Z I mean Alesso
collab is everything yeah
and love Alesso I do too like all the
songs are truly beginners yeah they are
I think we've seen yeah I think we've
seen everyone in Vegas at this point
that's a DJ it's generally Clarkson
except Kelly Clarkson are you ready for
our next Tori because it's also about
someone who has just hit after hit no
I'm not because I gotta let you know
that for all you thirsty [ __ ] out
there today's episode is also brought to
you by liquid IV because everyone's
talking about liquid IV is hydration
multiplier you've heard
how much we love it we especially love
it the morning after some questionable
choices even though it's not technically
for that it can be very helpful with
that very helpline I feel like alcohol
consumption is up in quarantine
therefore your liquid IV conception
should be up as well but Jackie have you
heard of their latest product liquid IV
energy multiplier their energy
multiplier tastes amazing just like
their lemon-lime flavor you mix it in
with water and drink energy multiplier
gives you a sustained energy boost with
absolutely no crash one of the things we
love most about liquid IV is that
they're on a mission to change the world
they've donated over two-and-a-half
million servings to date to places like
Haiti Uganda Puerto Rico and Nepal and
they're currently donating to healthcare
facilities and food banks within the US
with each purchase you make liquid IV
donates a serving to someone in need
around the world do you good feel good
what's not to love
half of Americans report that they fight
with daily fatigue so maybe he
recognized some of the signs of low
energy which is decreased focus lack of
motivation poor mood unhappiness who
wants that I feel like if you was suffer
from that in regular day quarantine days
it's definitely like on high alert for a
fatigue low energy lack of motivation so
they liquid IV multiplier energy
multiplier gives you sustained energy
throughout the day it helps you fight
fatigue without the crash it's a perfect
replacement for morning coffee and an
all natural alternative to processed
energy drinks premium matcha and green
energy blend tastes delicious and
provide lasting energy boost throughout
the day
the fatigue fighting boost you get from
a couple cups of coffee without the
crash on it contains a mixture of matcha
they use ginger high in antioxidants
that help you improve your mood and
focus and during these 40 times
everyone should be stocking up on
antioxidants they're very important get
25% off when you go to liquid IV calm
and use the code toast at checkout we've
been using liquid IV for like almost two
years now and it helps with so many
different things obviously just like
general feeling whether it's like the
teague lack of energy lack of motivation
but then also like I said after a long
Saturday night zoom um it can be very
very helpful on a Sunday night hangover
I mean Sunday morning hangover so yeah
it's weird Sunday night get 25% off when
you go to liquid IV com use the code
toast at checkout
that's 25% off anything you order on
liquid IDs website just go to liquid IV
com enter the promo code chose to save
25% and get better hydration and energy
that's liquid
EUCOM promo code toast don't wait start
fueling your adventures today love it
okay next story really sweet andy
grammer friend of the toast like one of
our favorite artists of all time and
it's crazy money then artists whose both
of those things you know his wife aja
details powerful home birth with baby
number two after previous c-section
delivering her second child was a
once-in-a-lifetime experience for andy
grammars wife asia the new mother of two
shared a photograph of herself with two
week old daughter Izzy to her Instagram
feed over the weekend revealing that she
had given birth at home after previously
having a cesarean section with the
couple's now two and a half year old
daughter my goddaughter Louisiana Louie
K oh my god those are cute names Lilly
and Izzy an Italy short for Israel she
was scared to do a home birth because
she thought something was wrong with her
since her first labor with Louie had
gone sideways it ended with all the
interventions plus ultimately a
c-section
she began in the caption of the suite
photo then you hear once a c-section
always a c-section right I thought maybe
I wasn't capable of this second birth
without an epidural plus a lot of the
comforts and reassurance of a hospital
our culture sometimes tells women that
we aren't able to give birth easily or
safely on her own she went on to recall
her struggle with hyperemesis gravidarum
an extreme form of morning sickness and
pregnancy that saying that the idea that
she would need hospital assistance was
perhaps set in for me by the
extraordinary amount of medical
attention that my pregnancy required
anyway she wound up delivering from home
and happy mom happy baby that's so crazy
like I think that the women who don't
get an epidural are like the bravest
most strongest most inspiring women on
the planet and they all deserve a Nobel
Peace Prize because in a world would I
ever give up drugs like I I need the
drugs like I'm not that I'm not that
strong whales I'm not that powerful but
there are women who are and they are my
heroes
ya know it is it is so brave and so
strong and like imagine just then you
can say that like ya know I said to
Olivia I'm like are you gonna to
drug-free like a human she's like are
you can t mean like Olivia Olivia is a
strongest person I know and like she of
course it's gonna get the drugs you know
yes
anyone could forego it would be her and
if anyone couldn't it would be you I
have a very low tolerance for pain and I
love drugs but you do know that actually
like medically biologically speaking
redheads have the lowest tolerance for
pain you know that right so like you
think you have the lowest threshold but
I actually do and I just like I just
tracker through it I use on that credit
no no there's no um proof that you have
that redhead gene it just could be no no
there's no proof you anytime I talk
about my low tolerance for pain like you
bring up the fact that like you are
genetically predisposed to like possibly
being low tolerance for pain but it's
like though is that possible it is but
you don't have a low tolerance for pain
like you get waxes more than anyone I
know
no but it's painful but I just suffer
through the pain I'm constantly
suffering through pain but I just said
her and I suffer through like a good
amount of pain but there's certain
things like I can't suffer through
therefore I have a lower tolerance for
pain okay okay sure I just like like to
remind you it's like well if you're out
here complaining like some of us are
suffering no I appreciate the the
heads-up you know it's like just I just
don't even think like I ever forgot you
know from the last time you tell me no
no I actually did think that you forgot
but I'm glad to know that you're
listening I did not forget great thank
you for remembering are you ready for
our next story because it's like some
teenage drama that I didn't see before I
saw it on a news and I'm like here for
this love triangle between well it sound
a love triangle according to Cole
Sprouse but rumors are flying that are
quote baseless that Cole Sprouse is
involved with kaya gerber okay yeah the
Riverdale star Cole Sprouse could be
confusing cuz Lilly Reinhardt is also a
Riverdale star but Cole Sprouse took to
his Instagram story overnight to address
rumors involving his relationship status
with Kaia Gerber as fans will know
twenty-seven-year-old Sprouse has been
an on-and-off romance with 23 year old
co-star Lilly Reinhardt for the past few
years in recent weeks however claims
have been made on social media about
Sprouse his possible involvement with
eighteen-year-old model Gerber after
seeing the speculation he took to his
Instagram story to set
set the record straight quote I tolerate
a lot of rumors and slander from people
online claiming to be my fans fans who
feel entitled to my privacy precisely
because I never indulged them but
attacking my friends baseless alec
accusations making my address and
sending death threats are all qualities
of insanity and fanta sysm he wrote
choose humanity
stop being clown emoji I think what he's
saying is don't worry be monkey that is
what I gathered from this Instagram
story personally but I actually don't
know what I gathered because I wasn't
sure what he was trying to say but
because he's so private and he like has
been forced to acknowledge his
relationship publicly because he's
dating a co-star but I don't think
because he's a celebrity actually is why
he's been forced no but some people like
go about their celebrity lives like
never really like giving details on
their personal life but he's dating his
co-star like he can't deny it yeah yeah
yeah it's both but like even if like
he's really the teenage heartthrob right
now like KJ KJ Apple was dating um you
know some girl from his hometown like we
would all want to know because he's a
celebrity and we love him yeah yeah no
totally and I I feel very in the middle
here like because celebrities do um
deserve fans to respect their privacy
and whatever those boundaries are but at
the same time like it is part of your
job so he just withhold so much and I
think that makes people crazy and people
want to know but because he was hold so
much like I think we don't know if he's
ever gonna tell us if him and Lily break
up but they might have already broken up
know but then they still we went through
this like a few months back remembered
that there was speculation they broke up
but then there were a lot of posts of
them together um I think they're still
together I agree I think any time we get
information it might be like months
after it happens
have you seen rumors about him and Kaia
Gerber though no but I believe there was
a photo oh well I haven't seen anything
and so then him addressing it now it's
like what's going on with Kai Gerber and
what's crazy to me is that like these
people all seem the same age but he's
actually 10 years older than Kaia Kerber
that's wild that is wild and for someone
who's really private I feel like he's
always releasing statements and like
speak
to the fans yeah in like really big
words you know yeah it's like these
Riverdale fans like I could barely like
understand what he was trying to say in
this Instagram story like let alone
teenagers who watch Riverdale even
though they're probably smarter than
maybe like so this is what he wrote when
I first stepped into a public
relationship this was one of the
foreseeable consequences and while I
truly never intended to indulge any part
of my life to the ravenous horde it's
clear my restraint and it's clear my
restraint in updating them has allowed
them to push their own agenda on to my
habits and lifestyle so in conclusion
please eat my delectable please eat my
delectable sorry see it's please eat my
delectable plump ass he wrote I'm pretty
sure he's saying grab a spoon in in
different words I would agree he said
making me post a goddamn white font
insta story like a divorced mother of
three wow he's really out for blood like
he's being a little nuts no no for sure
he's just like one of those celebrities
that and you know because he was a child
star maybe he didn't have a choice in
becoming somebody like maybe his parents
just decided like they had these two
beautiful twins like you guys are gonna
be stars and he's just one of these
celebrities who does not like being a
celebrity and he's gonna let us know
someone should set him up with Kourtney
Kardashian what it looks like what it
appears as though Cole Sprouse has
cracked I think what we're seeing is the
remnants of a cracking I wonder if him
and Lily are quarantined together well
so she was posting about her the dog
getting attacked in her apartment and it
did really seem like she was alone even
though that was just a vibe that I got
it was like quiet and there wasn't
anyone around you know who might know
the deets the snatcher will have to
watch a check-in with her maybe like
Lilly and Cole don't live far from one
another so they're able to quarantine
and visit each other and they don't have
that pressure on their relationship
I've been stuck one apartment for months
like maybe Lilly was like walking her
dog over to Cole's house when the attack
happened
perhaps her speculation speculation find
Efrem we'll find out from a smidge and I
wonder does Lily still live with kami
because they noticed they were living
together but maybe that was just in
Vancouver when they were filming but now
they're all back in LA I thought that
they were living together in LA
not in Vancouver LA too but that sounds
like too good to be true can they really
be such best friends I don't know like
the Riverdale cast I believe that this
is a trend in Hollywood like when you
all get really successful on a TV show
at a young age you start off like loving
each other like you're all in this
together or graduating class of 2020 and
then you start to hate each other I
don't know if they're there yet what
does it season 3 or season 4 season 4
sounds like you're there yet yeah but I
think they are actually still friends I
hope so okay fifth and final story a
little business also just one thing I do
think that when you're filming a show in
another land like Vancouver not like New
York LA Atlanta you are bound to stay
friends with your co-stars a little bit
longer than normal because it's just you
guys out there like it's there's no one
else for you to hang out with yeah I
would agree with that okay are you ready
for our business I'm sorry did you say
business yeah but it's actually sad
Benson's SBN I know I'm sorry but Neiman
Marcus is to file for bankruptcy as soon
as this week sources say at Reuters
Neiman Marcus group is preparing to seek
bankruptcy protection as soon as this
week becoming the first major US
department store operator to succumb to
the economic fallout from the corona
virus outbreak people familiar with the
matter said the debt Laden Dallas lease
company has been left with few options
after the pandemic forced it to
temporarily shut all fritz 43 of its
Neiman Marcus locations roughly two
dozen last call stores and it's to
Bergdorf's women's stores in New York
Neiman Marcus is in the final stages of
negotiating alone with its creditors
totaling hundreds of millions of dollars
which was the same sum of its operations
during bankruptcy proceedings according
to the sources it has also furloughed
many of its 14,000 employees the
bankruptcy filing could
within days though the timing could slip
the court the sources said Neiman Marcus
skipped millions of dollars in debt
payments last week including one that
only gave the company a few days to
avoid a default damn I have two things
to say one there's two Bergdorf's yeah
uh well maybe they mean Bergdorf's and
then Goodman's across the street which
is men's right the men's I don't know
because is there one in LA no I thought
there was just New York yeah I've seen
you of Barneys for a second there's one
downtown they probably mean because it
is two separate buildings so they do
have two buildings that require rent and
they're across the street from one
another so let's go with that now this
is a devastating story for a million
reasons but it's also like misleading
because when you hear companies like
filing for bankruptcy you're like oh
it's over no that's that's just actually
like a normal part not a normal but it's
a it's not a crazy thing to do as a
company it like offers you protection in
a lot of ways and it doesn't mean you're
done it doesn't mean that your local
Neiman Marcus is no longer going to be
there like in months so yes I agree it
is kind of misleading bankruptcy doesn't
mean that it's going out of business
shutting our doors right like plenty of
very successful companies have them at
one point filed for bankruptcy yeah but
it's just sad like that this is the
effect that it's had on this major
company all those people who don't have
jobs right now
um terrible it's just really sad
terrible terrible um that's like the one
thing like I like I like Shadle II like
love quarantine like I love being home
and I love that everyone's home like I
don't have to have FOMO from like other
things like there are certain things
about what's going on right now like I
don't hate I'm not gonna lie and I'm
starting to love like drinking in my
house like doing a bunch of puzzles like
I'm getting used to it but what I find
like so devastating is like people
losing their job their work not being
able to make ends meet like to me like
that's why all of this has to end like
now no a literally I think about it I
started to cry like every day the new
unemployment number going up like it's
so sad
yeah and that's where it's like not
funny anymore no not that any of this
was not ever funny but I think that we
most especially people our age are
trying to make the most out of our
situations you know learning taking the
time
you learn a new hobby and like you
saying that you've gotten you started
enjoying drinking your house and doing
puzzles it's like I know you would
rather be at 1oak you know all night so
it's not like you're loving quarantine
you're just finding ways to cope um and
it's just the whole situation is so sad
like and I think that's just a cloud
that hangs above everyone it's like yeah
in our own apartments we're struggling
with our own demons and trying to make
it through but then even when you like
just take a step back and think about
what other people might be going through
and it's so much worse it just makes you
feel deeply deeply sad oh and then not
to mention the other cloud of people who
have coronavirus are sick or losing
loved ones like there's also that like
the actual disease like taking people
having to die alone like not being able
to say goodbye to their loved ones like
that's awful awful and like just all the
health care workers working so hard
putting their lives on the line it's
just it's so everything every angle
perspective it's so sad um and I just I
think what we're doing is really helping
flattening the curve I think in New York
you know we've reached peak and it's
going down I just hope this ends as
swiftly and with this many healthy
people as possible amen okay let's talk
about Tiki watch anything this weekend
because I think we watch the same thing
and we need to talk about it well I
watched my skylight frame just all
weekend long so can I just talk about
that really quickly oh you guys can you
talk about this because I got one also
when I gifted it to my husband and he is
obsessed it's really cute it's a perfect
gift for anyone who you're not able to
see every day especially they're in
quarantine when you're not able to see
anyone but even during normal life like
your grandma your parents you live far
away from home it's a great way to feel
close to those you love when you're
separated because staying in touch with
the people we love is more important
than ever the easiest way to do it is
with a skylight a photo frame you can
email photos to anytime from anywhere
multiple people can send photos to the
frame so it's a great way to keep large
networks of friends and family in touch
it sets up effortlessly in under 60
seconds just plug it in use the
touchscreen to connect your wireless
network and enjoy sending photos to
skylight it's effortless everyone in
your family can just email photos to mom
skylight they'll pop up in her home in
seconds it has
a black frame so it looks like a real
photo frame that adds a beautiful touch
to your home
that's true like sometimes when you get
something like techie it's like ugly and
bulky and it like ruins your whole house
skylight frame is a gorgeous 10 inch
screen you can swipe through photos with
your finger and even tap to thank the
person who sent the photo skylight
frames has a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed if you don't
love your skylight they'll offer you a
full refund
you can preload it with your favorite
photos for a special Mother's Day gift
send pictures of you and your
significant other spouse grandparent
anyone you know honestly this is a
perfect gift for a grandparent who like
doesn't really know how to use
technology and like you just keep
sending photos and then you know that
they're like walking around their house
like seeing new photos of you and like
that brings them so much joy it's so
cute maybe they'll think it's magic like
how new photos are appearing that's so
cool you could even leave the little
message yeah and it's really easy to set
up so if you have parents or
grandparents for not really tech-savvy
it's really easy it shouldn't be a
problem
skylight frames if you guys want to get
a great holiday offer you can get $10
off your purchase at of a skylight frame
when you go to skylight frame calm enter
the code toast that's right just to get
$10 off your purchase of a skylight
frame go to skylight frame calm enter
the code toast
that's SK y l IG HT fr a.m. e.com and
the code is toast love it I think that's
such an amazing gift idea especially
right now I think there are so many
people who would totally appreciate that
and I got one for my husband and he
thinks it's the dopest thing ever
I mean if I go when when mine comes to
haven't got it yet when it comes I'm
going to leave it on Ben's nightstand
and then every morning like put up a
picture of that guy that's what going
around Ben would love that I don't think
there's anyone else he'd rather wake up
to every morning sorry I forgot to give
this as my weekend update but I'm the
man I married became a monster over the
weekend he do so we've been has been
really turning into content during this
quarantine and he's been releasing these
really really funny videos like he is
always singing and making up songs and
he's not really channeling his energy
into premium content like writing songs
about quarantine and on Friday he wrote
a song about duty he did it to the tune
of the simple plan's
I'm just a kid which is like one of
Ben's favorite songs I'm just all-around
great song and the lead singer of Simple
Plan posted it and deemed Ben and
followed Ben it was like they were
talking about how funny is and then it's
like a lover of punk like 90s punk early
two-thousands like that is bad like he's
just obsessed like we had that 90's men
play at his birthday party and ever
since this guy posted been like he's
been out of control like thinking he's
like a star and he like he gave me his
rider for the bedroom it's crazy oh my
god that is so crazy
um his song sent really though like he's
kind of a star those songs are so good I
know he's hard for me like she does he
feel some type of way since like
obviously Lou Combs came in and sort of
did what Ben's been doing but like on a
better level in like an earnest and
sincere way you know Ben is the type of
songwriter who really lifts up his other
songwriters so when I was in the kitchen
on Thursday like making dinner I heard
something I go into the living room and
Ben is listening to six feet apart by
Luke calms and Ben has like really been
missing his parents he's like very very
attached to his parents he sees them
multiple times a week and it's been
really hard for him and it's like been
even harder for them so I think he was
like gonna cry if I hadn't come in like
that song is really speaking to him and
he he's a lyricist who appreciates
lyrics even if they're not his he's a
songwriter who supports other
songwriters is what you're saying he
literally started the songwriters
support Foundation of America it's like
a really big SSF a it's like a huge
organization that's great and maybe
he'll get inspired like maybe he will
write an emotional one that's not just
about you know eating moldy cheese I
mean you know it's my dream like if only
Ben could have like become a rock star
like my life would be like on the road
with a rock star like that's all I want
that's why I like him so like jealous of
the lives of like musics physics biggest
spouses oh I completely agree they are
living the life of Riley living the life
like all I want to do is I want to die
tomorrow
got rid and come back as Nicole Hawking
like her life is amazing no her life is
amazing and also it's like so I think
just being a music spouse even if you
don't like love your husband's work like
I'm sure it's just I'm sure it's just
fun to be the spouse of a rock star but
imagine being the spouse of someone so
deeply talented who just had the drop of
a hat could just make you feel every
emotion
book and like make you cry and you look
at this person you're like you're sent
from God like well you just have this
like other world in your head like what
a talent you are imagine that yeah and
then like when when you're one of those
rock stars and you spend a lot of time
on tour if your spouse is with you first
of all like how fun is that and second
of all like life on the road like I
think as a musician like your whole life
is basically like on the label like
you're just like you could just buy
dresses and stuff like and just go
shopping on the labels time oh yeah for
sure I feel like you definitely get to
that point where it's like oh the label
stylist you know right right yeah
good times if you could trade places
with any musician spouse why would it be
Nicole Hawking because like their
backyard just looks so phenomenal I
think Lou Combs is the most talented
singer and songwriter of everyone who I
enjoy like I am so moved by his work and
so to like have that person next to me
every single day like I don't know what
I would do myself like I would just I
would just cry all the time yeah oh and
like Lou combs like not that it matters
like he is so successful so like to be
able to go on a tour like up stadiums
it's not the same as going on like a
club tour which is good too but all I'm
saying is like if I'm choosing someone
like I want someone playing arenas like
I don't want someone playing like
theaters you know yeah definitely I mean
I could definitely think of some other
options to like um and even like single
options you know because like Brett
Eldredge oh yeah Josh Groban that I feel
is like a sad tour no I think Josh
Groban is like the most eligible
bachelor in the entire world
he's so talented he's so talented he
like he he's like on rabbit I like jr.
and he's handsome and he's funny
okay he's handsome in like a dorky way
but okay he's handsome I know I do I
agree he's totally handsome another one
that's like so perfect and I feel like
we really got to see like how good it is
to be the life like the wife of a rock
star
is with the Jonas Brothers like they all
were having so much fun they had that
plane like daily went on a crazy tour
yeah they're all and also them and all
their spouses are like young
and fun and they drink and they jewel
like they're just like kids living the
life yeah totally I would agree with
that I would take really just no I mean
if Ben wants to go on a tour of our
block like I'm coming oh my god no
that's why you should really encourage
this like you never know where it could
take him
that's true so I actually am a big fan
of Ben's work right now like it makes me
laugh out loud and you know who's Ben's
number-one fan actually who my husband
over this cute he's like always cry like
laughing so hard at Ben's Instagram
videos and like I think Ben like we'll
send him some content like early to like
see it Sac State yeah they have like a
collaborative relationship and they
things like don't I mean he'll never see
this but I know he really likes ever
watch the good show ya know like he's
not watching our zoom happy hour also
really quickly just it's important to
note that like when we talk about like
where this could take been his dream
like his like his icon and this whole
thing is weird out of the end connect so
it's like he's not becoming like Luke
Ryan anytime soon but he could become
the next Weird Al Yankovic you know what
like I actually see I see the
correlation me too
okay can we get into things that we
watch this weekend because I watched two
bits of things the first one I think you
watch too because our little sister has
been bullying everyone into watching it
it's a show on Netflix called Outer
Banks and it is the content that we have
been waiting for when we said we need a
new show oh wait Claudia either has to
sneeze or has to say something I only
watched the first three episode so I
wanted to recap it tomorrow or the next
day so just so you could say whatever
you want but like please don't spoil
anything okay that's so fair I think
that's actually perfect because let's
give the toaster it's like I watched it
all day yesterday and I finished it in
one day but there's actually a lot of
episodes and they're really long so
let's give it a few days and then we can
recap the plot but I just want to say
like when we were talking about how we
need a new show that's fabulous this
that like for quarantine this was the
show like someone a Netflix slipped like
pushed up the Outer Banks release date
because this is the show you guys this
is the show we've been waiting work for
it's teen drama beautiful setting it has
everything that you could look for great
cast like Deacon Claybourne from
Nashville isn't it
um and then the young people I don't
know them they're their up-and-comers
and I love that um and I think it's a
really great show I think it's very
toasty and Snitch was right on the money
Thank You snitch
so let's make it the official toast
series of the weekend I mean of the day
and maybe we'll recap it tomorrow or
Wednesday depending on when I finish it
I you know I have a lot to do today so
we'll see I'm like a vibe from the
toasters as to like how much time they
need so it might be like a few days long
activity but it's it's what we've been
waiting for yeah I feel like it's
fabulous
yeah it's it's really good and it's not
what you it's not so I mean it's like
obviously a little stupid because
everything is but um it's good Subin
yeah and I don't think a show is
actually good unless it's stupid in some
way no for me personally I'm not
interested in things that aren't stupid
no not at all I'm a stupid girl with
stupid interests um also the other thing
that I watch this but you know it's not
stupid Oh what my decision to wear my
Felix Craig glasses almost every day of
quarantine because it's helped me with
the blue light so much so much Felix
great glasses filter out 90% of blue
light in the most damaging range and
eliminates 99% of glare through a
proprietary industry-leading lens
technology only available with Felix
grey 9 and 10 Felix right customers
report significant symptom relief their
frames are hand finished and durable
super lightweight Italian made from
Italian acetate with over 200,000 happy
customers Felix grey isn't the right
choice it's the only choice
by the way Claire is legit like I wore a
pair of glasses for a while that had
such a bad glare and I didn't realize it
when I went to bed every night I had a
migraine from wearing the glasses all
day like the glare reflecting in your
eye my eyes are very sensitive and it
has a lot to do with when I get
migraines I'm like if it's super like
right outside I could get a migraine so
glasses have a lot to do with with how
you sleep if you have migraines like
there's a million things headaches
there's a million things that having
like the right glasses can help with so
Felix Grey's the right choice you can
order online their glasses shipped
directly to you with a hard case and a
lens cloth included you could try them
for 30 days risk-free and if your
screens aren't easier on your eyes you
can send them back for a full Rico
refund go to Felix grey glasses dot-com
slash toast for the absolute best
quality blue light filtering glasses on
the market that's Fe Li X G RA Y glasses
calm slash toasts do what we did and
start taking care of your eyes feel
better work smarter when you're working
from home now so much like you
definitely need a pair of blue light
glasses shipping and returns are totally
free at Felix gray Felix gray glasses
dot-com / toast Thank You Felix great
now we could talk about what Jackie
wants to talk about can I guess is it I
still believe yes okay so this movie is
based on the true story of the Christian
singer
Jeremy camp and I saw like previous for
it a really long time ago it starring KJ
and Britt Robertson and Shania Twain and
Gary Sinise and I'm like that is my
dream team and I was so excited to see
it when it came out but of course it
came out like the week of quarantine and
snitch and I had like big plans to see
it but we couldn't but they wound up
releasing it early like on Apple iTunes
so you confront it it's expensive though
cuz it's like buying a ticket you know
it's 15 how much $15 to rent them away
yeah yeah but that's like instead of
going to see it in theaters and I
watched it and like I'm not I I don't
want to say anything negative because I
loved it so much and like this story is
so beautiful there were moments that
were just some things didn't add up to
me um but it was so good it just got me
and my feelings I I don't think it's
possible to watch it and not cry so if
you're looking for a good cry um that's
simile you have to be in the mood for a
cry like a cry movie like if you're not
expecting it can really ruin your day
yeah or sometimes you watch a crime
movie and you're like not really into it
enough that you don't cry and then
you're like wait is there something
wrong with me yeah I mean what movie has
made you cry like the most ever
oh the pursuit of happiness I think that
was like the earliest time I remember
like sobbing uncontrollably but then
there was a time a few years ago where I
watched the last song and I was wailing
I'd already seen it like a million times
and it just like hit me sideways
I was wailing like until I fell asleep
it was like when Zach and I were dating
and I think he was like is this [ __ ]
okay said that I cried at first was
member a little princess oh it's like
that weird Disney movie where like a
girl's dad like goes missing in war and
then she goes to an orphanage and
they're really mean to her but then like
the dad
defining her and it's like when they've
her when he when he ends up finding her
in the orphanage like and they were so
terrible turned the orphanage because
she was like this beautiful rich young
girl and then I yes right but then when
her dad died she couldn't pay for like
the proper orphanage does she was like a
part of the orphanage likes the kids who
like we're also staff and like her life
was just like so miserable grow worse
were so mean to her bullying her she
lost all of her like favorite prized
possessions and then one day like her
dad just shows up in the rain and it's
not to spoil it but like when her dad
finds her like he first of all we
thought he was dead
second of all he's about to rescue her
from this like life of misery with these
Amin Mean Girls
and they just like embrace in the rain
and I just I remember crying and never
having cried from a movie book before
I'm like being shocked that I could be
impacted emotionally from something
that's like not real and it was really
like I remember it
and I remember nothing like I have the
worst memory but I remember it so
vividly yeah Wow
it said you know I think that was like a
very formative movie for everyone yeah
where is that that girl the actress who
played the young Sarah was phenomenal
yeah she really was I think that movie
is on Disney class I can't watch it it's
literally so heavy like there are
certain movies I get huge pits about
like I do need to see it like
Schindler's List of course you need to
see it but I never want to see it again
like certain movies have such like hit
worthy plots and like they put you in
such a bad place emotionally like you
need to see them just for the sake of
seeing them then I never want to see it
again that's how I felt about pursuit of
happiness I saw it and I never saw it
again
oh my god I guess ultimately though it's
a hat like it has a happy ending
I guess all of those movies do though
but the way like going through it it was
just it was so sad did you ever see that
Jacob Tremblay movie where he's like has
the one birth defect wonder oh my god I
could not see that I saw it I was crying
but I knew what I was you like when you
see the trailer you know what you can
expect but I was just like crying I mean
I can't I don't know do something -
crying she was so sad it's hard what me
and Ben were like if I go to the movies
and we went online to look at tickets
and we watched the trailer for Wonder
and I literally started hysterically
crying from the trailer like I couldn't
get over it all day and I never saw it
because I just couldn't ya know that was
that was a tough one it's also weird
what to like when you're crying in
movie theater you know yeah it's like
you feel embarrassed oh and does your
husband do this thing Ben does this
thing that drives me in sane will be
like watching something sad and like if
I start to cry like he'll turn his head
and look at me and like watch me cry and
it makes me so angry that like I
literally will stop watching stuff with
him
we were watching I want to say was even
like One Tree Hill in the very early
seasons like something terrible happened
and I was like getting emotional I was
getting choked up over this like soap
opera and Ben starts to look at me and I
literally pause the TV I'm like get out
like I just want look at me watch TV
like what do you looking at me for like
it just it drives me nuts and I'm like
embarrassing I'm then I'm like crying
over a TV show but like I don't know
he's crying is he crying - or he's just
like making fun of me I don't know I
feel so like vulnerable I'm like get out
of my room it's so vulnerable I can't
like yeah and when I'm watching with
someone else like I will do everything
in my power not to cry it's like you're
not gonna know you're not gonna know
that I was upset or all like put my
pillow strategically so that like I am
crying but you have no idea Wow um
anyways I still believe was really good
but a little expensive yeah so like if
you had seen it in theaters do you think
you would have been like pleased I do I
think I because I wouldn't have been on
my phone and stuff I would have been
like really involved and I just loved
everyone who was in it there were some
like the writing wasn't like the best
but it was really good it's a really
sweet story and the music is really good
because it's all about like Christian
music
it's very also it's very very like face
heavy so if you're into that like I
think you'll love it and if you're not
into that
I just wouldn't recommend it for you I
feel like Tonya rad should watch it I
feel like she would love it oh my god I
nice texture I should ask her if she's
watched it yeah I feel like it's like a
litter she should have been in it a
hundred percent I'm gonna text after
this that's so funny I actually spoke to
her the other day she's literally the
funniest person ever and you know she
she's like very well-connected but she's
like not bragging about it you know
she sure does like she'll drop something
in the conversation I'm like did you
just say that yeah love to see it is
there anything else we need to discuss
today this was a nice long episode it's
only Monday oh my
I can't even I'm out of puzzle I was
saying this on my patreon
day-in-the-life which you should
definitely check out like if you're
interested and like what I do um but I
would say like I was in such a terrible
mood yesterday and this morning leading
up until the show and like the show just
like turn my day around and that if this
if this is the like impact that it has
on other people like I'm so grateful
that we got to do this like I will have
a much different day now than I would've
if we didn't do the toast yeah yeah to
be honest it also makes me feel good to
know that like you also had a terrible
weekend not that I'm happy you had a bad
weekend but there was something in the
air this weekend like when me and Ben
got into bed we're like this was a
terrible weekend and part of it was my
own doing like I put myself in the work
like I had an anxiety the whole weekend
and had anxiety this morning I won't
feel like satisfied until people hear
what I have to say and it's just it
makes me like a little happy to know
that like everyone had a bad weekend
yeah we're just on the Ramona coaster
that is quarantine and I think that
there's a lot of a lot of downs but the
toast is just one of those highs and I
think that's why we feel so so much
responsibility towards you know the
toasters and we just and we want to make
you guys happy and cheerful and we hate
when we do the opposite Hey like it's
that's the whole point of like why I get
so emotionally invested and like when
people are upset with me it's because
like I just can't believe like I somehow
become the psyche controversial person
like all I've ever wanted to do is like
be funny and make people laugh like I've
always wanted to be this like and as
someone who just absolutely craves like
universal likeness like all I want is
for everyone to like me and like I
actually have the opposite like I don't
know how I got to this place and I'm so
like disappointed in myself
and that's why like I Oh wait like I
don't people like like thrive on
controversy and they like love it
there's no such thing as bad press where
like I wholeheartedly disagree and I
just want like I value our platform so
much and I value like the the fans and
the followers who gave us this platform
and like I just don't want to [ __ ] that
up and I find myself [ __ ] it up
recently and I need to stop yeah but I
mean that's the you live and you learn
and oh you couldn't do is change how you
are going forward you know so that's
that's that on that thank you guys so
much for listening to the Morning Joe
someone a morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching
this video on YouTube please subscribe
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts we found so that's
about if I - teacher Public Radio I
haven't cast box all the places so ever
you listen to podcasts find out the
morning choice and leave a five star
view about our beautiful stunning and
smart we are we are also available for
premium content on Instagram and we're
at 197 thousand I could just really get
to 200,000 during the quarantine so
that's at the morning shows we're always
posting printing stuff we love you guys
very much we hope you have a wonderful
day full with happiness and no pits have
a great day bye